[Musik]
mein Name ist Anna Kaiser ich bin
assistenzprofessorin für
Kulturgüterschutz an der Universität für
Weiterbildung Krems einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen
militärisch war ich die letzten fünf
Jahre kompaniekommandantin
[Musik]
Strasser bin seit 22 Jahren jetzt an der
volksopertal Wien ich habe mich
entschlossen mich zum Scharfschützen
ausbilden zu lassen um die kritische
Infrastruktur schützen zu können
schutzkritische Infrastruktur ist
sicherlich einer der ganz wichtigen
Aufgaben des österreichischen
Bundesheers einfach weil es um das
alltägliche Leben der Österreicherinnen
und Österreicher geht da geht es um
Krankenhäuser es geht um
verkehrsnotenpunkte es geht um Einkaufen
es geht wenn man es bisschen überspitzt
formulieren möchte ums Überleben der
Bevölkerung
zum schutzkritische Infrastruktur
braucht es nicht unbedingt das was man
sich jetzt als Angriffskrieg vorstellt
oder Landesverteidigung Österreichs das
kann auch viel viel früher eintreten
denkt man an die covid-krise 2020 vor
allem denkt man aber auch an
Naturkatastrophen oder auch ein
Terroranschläge
[Musik]
sperrenbezogen
ich bin stolz dass ich als Milizsoldat
zu Sicherheit der Menschen in Österreich
beitragen kann
es ist die Familie es sind die Lieben
daheim es ist es ist unsere Kultur auf
die wir so stolz sind ja das ist zu
schützen das ist ja gar nicht mehr so
weit weg jetzt ja also Russland Ukraine
das das diese paar hundert Kilometer
dann macht man sich natürlich Gedanken
die aktuellen Entwicklungen in der
Ukraine ist der Begriff Krieg viel
realer geworden wenn es denn so weit ist
werde ich schießen
ich habe keine moralischen oder
ethischen Probleme für Österreich die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher da zu
sein und sie im Notfall auch zu
verteidigen